[Music]
[Music]
mmm welcome to wisdom for life
where we sift through philosophy to find
practical advice that you can use in
your
everyday life hi i'm dan hayes and today
i'm with my co-host dr greg sadler
and we are talking about the reddit
aita forum and what we can make of it
and we're going to do something a little
bit
different today in that we're going to
be looking at well let's call them case
studies
although they're not exactly case
studies in the classic sense
taken directly from that reddit forum
before that we're going to have to talk
a bit about
some preliminary topics as well not
maybe not everybody's as familiar with
the aita
what is that signifies so this is where
we have to be very careful to not
run a foul of fcc regulations
and there's a word that we're going to
be gesturing at
and circling around this entire time and
we're going to supplement it
by calling people jerks or pots's or
schmucks or whatever
else we want but it's am i the
a-hole right and it's it's a very
popular forum on reddit now
i know you use reddit more than i do
you're you're a bit better
in that neck of the internet woods right
i
i encountered it through twitter and
there is
they have an account and they post their
stuff and it gets a lot of discussion on
twitter and i was like wow this is
actually
pretty good stuff i might use some of
this in my classes and you and i have
used some of the
cases in it on the show in in uh
questions or references before but you i
mean you've been on reddit a lot longer
and you use it a lot more than than i do
what's what's your
view on this this forum it is a very
interesting place you know sometimes
it's you know it's like moss eisley you
know
no greater uh realm of scum and villainy
um but but also it has some incredible
stuff and
uh and really insightful
conversations that you see from all
sorts of backgrounds
the it really kind of depends on the
communities that each one of these
subreddits or these communities that
kind of reside within reddit
depend upon and it's the moderation
they're in and so you can set it up with
a very like
hey we're only going to talk about
science and anything that is off topic
is automatically banned and so it's like
we are here for science and science only
and anyone's going to be here for like
memes or walls
you can go find someplace else to go um
where
and and it really if you if you do that
and and you just
find your the goal of what you want to
do there um
very narrowly you can have really good
and focused conversations
it really seems that a lot of subreddits
go through
a wave of oh they're small and they're
easy to moderate
um and they get they're good and then
all of a sudden they get popular and
then
it takes a lot more work to actually
moderate them and to maintain
the the good discussions yeah and and
then either you
find a good moderation team and the
right amount of tools to actually
solve these issues or it kind of goes
off the rails
and and you and if you also
like fringe ideologies and just
you know if you're like flat earthers
you can find a group of flat earthers
you can find a group of pretty much
anything there
um except for they've been uh recently
at least you know within the last couple
years been
pretty harsh on uh tamping down any like
white nationalists or things along those
lines you know it seems like
this particular subreddit though
it draws in people from all over the
place it's it's not quite so focused you
know like there's also you know the we
should talk about
at some point the reddit for stoicism
which is quite good
you know or other philosophies of life
this this is an advice column one and i
think there's a lot of other advice
column
reddits out there as well
but there's something about this one
that that really
you know captivates people it and i've
seen a lot of really
excellent conversations being had
in this this particular subreddit
um so we should talk about the forum
itself it's
you know as we're saying pretty popular
uh right now it has 2.5 million members
and that those are people who've
actually like signed up for it a lot of
other people are like me who
i don't know are you you're not a member
of it are you or no i lurk
yeah then well there there you go so
there's who knows how many lurkers there
are and uh it's you know
there's a really great line here uh a
catharsis for the frustrated moral
philosopher in
all of us and a place to finally find
out if you were in the wrong
in an argument that's been bothering you
tell us about any non-violent conflict
you've experienced
give us both sides of the story and find
out if you're
right or if you're the jerk
you know what we're talking about there
and that's that's the description
yeah that's the description they have of
it and a lot of the
posts really do seem to fit that
description i guess if if they don't
they
just delete them right or down vote them
or right and
that's one of the main features of
reddit is there's an
up vote and down vote system and so if
you think something is quality you
upvote it and you only can do it once or
if you don't think it's quality you
downvote it
and there's different philosophies of
different portions of reddit about
what the upvote and downvote are
somewhere like is this
quality content or is it or is it just
hungry or disagreeing yeah
yeah you know it's interesting because
on youtube
you've also got an up and a down vote
right but
if you down vote in youtube that
actually makes the video get served to
more people
just just as much as an upvote does
they're only looking for engagement
they're not looking for
is this something worth checking out
right
um because you know the engagement
especially if it's controversial
uh makes people more engaged with it and
so
yeah the goal is engagement for
engagement's sake or engagement in order
to sell ads
then you know you want to be promoting
the things that
are controversial or um or
inflammatory yeah so lead us through
what what happens in this forum
how does it actually work so someone
presents this story and they try to say
they say try to present this in you know
giving both sides of the story in order
to give us as much information as
possible
try to play a little bit of devil's
advocate for yourself don't try to just
whitewash your particular opinion
because the whole point of here is to
actually find out the truth if you
are the the putts um
or not and and so you are then given
um you you give a story and you say
am i the the putts and
um then people will then chime in with
um either
uh yta or you're the
the a-hole or on uh
nta or not the a-hole on and on
uh n-a-h which is like you know
there's no no a-holes here and
on e-s-h and everyone sucks here so
everyone's the a-hole i and i've seen
variations too where they'll be like
well there's five people in this
situation
you definitely are a jerk and this other
person over here is a jerk and this
other person's
kind of a jerk and then the other two
are okay
that would be somewhere in between esh
and yta you know you can sort of
pile these into each other and i think
it's actually kind of cool that people
do in fact vote on them when i was
looking for some
that would be fun for us to talk about
tonight you could actually click on
their some of them were labeled as
definitely this way definitely
that way so you know
and then you have all the the people
that are participating that don't give
the
their own opinions but they can then
upvote or downvote the opinions of
others and so true
yeah yeah that there seems to be some
sort of consensus making
um to what are the the most
moral decisions or at least through you
know a very popularity
base and which is it's just interesting
and if you're like a moral philosopher
this is like
a smorgasbord i have actually been
thinking
i i this this is kind of a just an idea
i had today
as as i was getting ready for this
wouldn't it be fun
you teach a little bit of moral theory
you know each of the main
moral theories that we typically teach
in an ethics class
and then spend about you know a couple
weeks just going through the forums
letting the students pick
which particular situations cases
dilemmas whatever we're going to call
them
from that forum and require them to
participate
in reddit and you know say something
there they could do it anonymously i
think right
but then also like you know do some
analyses i think this is actually a
really fertile ground for contemporary
ethics training um
so for you as a a teacher or a professor
um teaching these courses um you could
go and you can make a subreddit just for
your class
and you can make it private and only
invite those people
and then you can curate some of these um
case studies and throw them up there and
have people present their particular
moral findings from this and then let
the rest of the class then actually vote
on people so that would be really
interesting
yeah we'll have to talk more about this
that's a side note but yeah i think you
know there's so much that could be
done with this and i know that ethic
we'll call it ethics twitter right
they're interested in this aita
forum on on reddit uh in in so far as it
shows up on twitter and there's a lot of
great discussion that goes on about like
and the discussion isn't just like are
you this or aren't you this
there's a lot of um thinking about like
well
what made you this you know to what
degree
are you this or how could you fix this
and people sometimes give useful
bits of advice to the the original
poster
or yeah like either advice going forward
or advice
in the moment you could have done this
at the time yeah or
like you need to get into counseling or
something like that
so so we should talk very briefly we're
throwing this term around without
actually
using the term itself um
just like the you know other interesting
vernacular terms philosophers have been
devoting
some attention to trying to define just
what goes into being
this kind of jerk that we call an a-hole
there's a guy robert sutton who did it
he's literally written
not just the book but several books on
the topic
and he has some interesting things to
say that are found in a vox
interview that we'll link to about what
makes a person that
so i'm going to read a little bit of
this then we'll talk about it
in just a moment he says there's a lot
of academic definitions but here's how i
define it
this kind of person is someone who
leaves us feeling demeaned de-energized
disrespected
and or oppressed in other words someone
who makes you feel like dirt
and then the interviewer says so this
this is somebody who doesn't care about
other people
and then he makes an interesting
distinction he says i would make this
distinction between
temporary and certified a-holes because
all of us under the wrong conditions can
be temporary ones
i'm talking about someone who is
consistently this way
who consistently treats other people
this way it's more complicated than
simply saying
that an a-hole is someone who doesn't
care about other people in fact some of
them really do care
they want to make you feel hurt and
upset they take pleasure in it so
there's
it sounds like he's saying that there's
a bit of a sadistic side to the people
who are not just temporarily or
situationally
a-holes but the people who you can say
that that person really you know when
somebody says what do you think about
joe you said
he's an a-hole when you're describing it
as a character trait right
there's there they do care about what
other people um
think feel decide but
they they care about it in the wrong way
and i think some of the cases that we're
going to see are
examples of people caring the wrong way
right it's not just not
caring right i'm always i'm a big
proponent of
really being careful with the uh
adjectives that we define people under
um
now why why why is that i think i
probably know
some reasons behind that but um because
you don't know a lot of the times why
the people are acting the way
we have very little direct interaction
with
someone's mind unless you're like
looking at it like an fmri and then even
that
is like well what does that actually
tell you yeah yeah
and so you can't like someone cuts you
off in traffic and
you know were they intentionally going
to try to make you feel bad
or was there some extenuating
circumstances doesn't mean that their
action was good just because they had
good intentions or
um or why they were doing this but
to then automatically label them the the
jerk or the super jerk or the putts here
um
i almost feel like we're getting like
ego super ego and whatnot
um but to uh once you've defined them
you've stuck them in this category that
is like
the bad category and once you put them
into the bad category
it allows you to at least partially
dehumanize them
yeah and so it leads to almost like a
mental shorthand right you don't you
don't have to think
things through you already know what box
they fit into
so you know how to um
how to treat them you've already framed
it right
and i guess the the one that seems to
happen a lot in america is like
you're a criminal like you commit a
crime and you're a criminal and you're
potentially a criminal for life and now
you have this
uh cloud that hangs over you which makes
it much more difficult for you to
you know reintegrate into society and
on you know it removes this ability for
someone to actually have the ability to
change their character it's like this
idea of an immutable character that is a
very interesting point
and you know there there are different
we talk about different um
philosophical views or perspectives on
on punishment
and and criminality and you know when
when we were younger um like when we
were kids there was an
emphasis on rehabilitation that
eventually fell
out in in part because rehabilitation is
expensive
and um it it doesn't always work and
and we've really switched in america to
this retribution model
that that fits in with you know once a
criminal always a criminal
why are we like when i was teaching at
indiana state prison
one of the common things i'd hear even
from my family members is why are we
wasting tax dollars on these
these people you know and you point out
to them that
this is probably the best use of tax
money we can use it
radically cuts recidivism meaning people
don't go back to prison if they've if
they've had a decent like liberal arts
education which is a great
you know reason to argue for liberal
arts education
as opposed to like just business or
things like that
and they just wouldn't want to hear it
they'd be like those bums don't deserve
it
you know and if you look at
other countries where there is still
more of an emphasis
on you know if not just uh
getting away from retribution you could
still have like deterrence you could
still have incapacitation
but there is this this sense that well
sooner or later we have to reintegrate
these people into society
where that's part of the culture um
their attitudes towards criminality are
are a good bit different than ours ours
in the present you know
because like i was pointing out it
wasn't always it wasn't always like that
um right and it's kind of like you know
uh the immediate gratification of not
paying for this
versus the the long-term gratification
of having a better society
less criminality in general um and also
vastly improving the lives of a large
portion of your populace
yeah you know when i talk to about like
these these people are going to come out
and have to be reintegrated into society
you know you think about the toll that
um imprisonment takes
on families of prisoners you know and
and the damage that it does to the
social fabric i mean we could probably
do a whole show just on talking about
punishment and criminal justice um
i'll say one other thing too this is a
bit of a like total digression but i
think it could be interesting to the
listeners
and you might have some ideas about this
so one of the
prevalent complaints about um prisoners
is that they get to watch tv in prison
you know
and it's viewed as like they're on easy
street you know they have three square
meals a day and
and they get to actually have like you
know um
tvs in their cell and the reality of
that is like
almost the opposite they have to pay for
those
and they'll pay like anywhere from like
200 to 300
for a little crappy tv set that's in
their cell
and you know you might get good
reception you might not get it
and the guards love for prisoners to
have
tvs you know why makes mordoso
that's one big part of it and it makes
them docile in that
if they're sitting in their cell they're
sitting at their cell they're not
they're not out doing something else
it's something you can take away from
them if they misbehave
ah so having a tv
is more likely to produce compliance
because it's
one big ticket item that they can they
can take away from you if you misbehave
so you know this whole this idea that
people have they're like oh they
shouldn't have anything
they should be like just stuck in their
cells with nothing to do
think about their their crimes all day
long as if they're in solitary
um it's just terrible which is yeah and
solitary is what i think it's like
considered a
was it a human's right violation by most
of the world
yep they're starting to realize it
affects the the brain over time and some
of the effects never completely wear off
you know what what the the prison
industry wants is prisoners doing things
keeping themselves occupied
so that they're more compliant and you
know creating less trouble but
back to back to the uh
aith yeah yeah um so
as i was thinking about this and looking
at cases i was like and we were talking
about using these in ethics i was like
you know there's actually a lot of
sophisticated moral reasoning going on
in these
these could be quite quite helpful for
us
not just for i mean some people do it
for entertainment right
just like some people have dating apps
and don't actually use them as dating
apps they just
flip back and forth looking at people
right but that's
that's not all that that's going on
there what what else do we have
um i guess we could
it's useful for the questioner to get
feedback from a wide range of
perspectives
um you know without having to like go to
your friends and to like save face by
doing this anonymously
that's interesting yeah um and it it's a
little bit
um pulls you back because you're no
longer having to deal with these
uh social consequences that you would
have in other contexts
there are people that you see going on
there and they're saying like i'm gonna
go anonymous for this because
my family or friends actually read this
um but yeah that's that you know there
are other places that people can go for
advice
quora is another website that i'm i'm
pretty active on but
i think that for getting advice about
these things
you get you get a better range of advice
on reddit aita
than you do asking questions in quora
and it also like it gives you the
ability to
um reflect on some of your own
particular behaviors so for example if
if you see someone
and you're like oh man like i do that
all the time and they're like everyone's
like
you are the jerk like oh
i could maybe work on that yeah you know
it's interesting one of the things so
when we do moral theory right there's
like
substantive moral theories that are
typically about okay what what makes
things right or wrong or good or bad and
what are virtues and vices like and then
there's a whole field of moral
development
and in thinking about how we do in fact
develop a lot of it
is by looking at what other people do
and then how other people view it not
not just doing it ourselves and then
getting bumped on the nose and you know
them saying bad dog to you or something
but watching other people screw up and
seeing the
reactions to it and then very
importantly
so you know i'll bring in one theorist
here lawrence kolberg
some people are probably familiar with
his six stages of moral development
that's very contestable whether these
things really work out that way
but one of the things that he stressed
was that it's not enough just to come to
judgments or come to
verdicts about stuff it's very important
to look at the
reasoning processes the the ways in
which people figure these things out
what what they appeal to you know at a
very low level it's well don't do that
because you're going to get punished and
then at
like a higher level it could be well i
don't want to do that because i don't
want to hurt people's feelings you know
at a higher level it could be well this
is going to be a violation of somebody's
rights or
the social contract or you know abstract
principles
and when we look at these advice columns
like this
and we see why people are saying yes you
are a jerk
and here's why it's you know sometimes
it's like man that's just a not cool
thing to do dude right which is not
telling you a lot
but sometimes it's like well you know
this is doing this and this is your
assumption here
and here's why this is this is a bad
thing and we
i think you're right we can learn a lot
especially if we see a bit of ourselves
in those people or or we see like you
know like i've got kids and of course
kids are always in process and
quite often they're not as good as you'd
like them to be
and you could you could be like oh yeah
that that
that could be the vector that this kid
is going down if we're not careful
you know our students or whoever right
right and how much you want to or need
to
intervene what is your duty to these
people
um yeah be another you know
uh aita question
you mean like whether or not you should
whether or not you're a good person or a
bad person
by responding in certain ways right yeah
i guess yes you know if like
if it's your child like what what are
the the things that you
you need to do in order to
i guess try to at least teach them
because you you it's kind of like the
you can lead a horse to water um and
as much as you teach them they might not
come away with the exact same thoughts
you are
rarely do they ever maybe i'm just not
doing it well you know
[Laughter]
um well maybe you should have been with
uh what uh captain von trapp with the
little whistle that would have got them
in line
you need a you need a good governess
though to like build you legitimacy
right you got to have
you got to have the the what are the the
honey with the medicine
right right right a spoonful of sugar
exactly yeah
you know um one of the things that we
were going to talk about
uh as well as so people are making
judgments is it
is it bad to be judgmental uh does that
like
is there something about participating
in this forum that automatically
by virtue of you making judgments makes
you kind of
a jerk in the process what do you think
i think at least for this form it's
definitely not
on being a jerk whatsoever because
they're specifically asking for the
advice
um and they they can take it or leave it
i guess the point where i think being
judgmental
um comes into a question
is when you are
have a specific uh moral reasoning
that you are trying to impose on someone
else
without them also buying into this moral
reasoning
yeah i i think there there's you could
have certain
knee-jerk reactions that are like
judgmental in that bad way and i've seen
that in some of these
um aita forums but it's interesting
because then
pretty quickly somebody else will weigh
in and say you know you're making these
assumptions this is this is actually
off base you know compared to what the
person originally posted
like you know if you do post something
about your kids somebody is going to
tell you you're a bad parent
you know guaranteed there's no winning
there
well there is there is winning so this
is another thing too
i was thinking about is what's good
about this
the people who post now they if they
really are a jerk
they're getting called out by asking
people to say hey
am i being a jerk and that could be good
for them i think in a lot of cases
other people say no no you're not the
a-hole
the other person is or nobody is and
don't beat yourself up about this or
maybe
you know the person the other person is
gaslighting you
or abusing you or things like that you
get out of this situation i think that
that's actually quite helpful
um some of the original posters are
probably getting some
fairly decent advice out of this right
and support too
and even vindication because you know
you could get into it and be like
okay i i've been people are telling me
that i'm a jerk
i don't really know i mean i think i'm
actually in the right what do you think
of twitter or reddit or whoever and
in some of the ca a lot of the cases
people are like no they're right
you are a jerk but in some cases they're
like no no you
actually have a good point there you
might not have articulated as well maybe
you shouldn't have shouted it at
somebody or
you know thrown all their clothes in the
street or something like that but
you you actually are in the right and
and i think getting that that
vindication
that's probably pretty powerful for for
some people
yeah especially if they they are in a
situation where
you know a person or maybe a number of
people are
potentially uh acting in bad faith or
gaslighting or
one of these yeah narcissistic traits um
to actually have some ability and some
outside
like of your your small bubble so like
oh there there's some grounding here
um and to go back to the eye
question of like is it good or bad is it
is judgmental
being judgmental a bad thing and this is
kind of something that that you've
brought up a couple of times that is
uh it is good to make moral judgments
and i was wondering if you would expand
on that
yeah i and i think i may have brought it
up talking about my students who usually
come into
ethics classes and and you know intro to
philosophy classes
um having learned that it's bad to be
judgmental and they and they draw from
that that it's bad to have judgments at
all we should all be like you know
totally respectful of everybody else's
points of view
and i say you don't have to buy into any
of that i want to liberate you from that
you can make as many judgments as you
want you just have to have some sort of
reasonable basis for it
and you have to be willing to be called
out on it
and other people get to judge your
judgments
so you know and it's it's interesting to
see the the relief that you see on a lot
of students faces because i guess
they're really getting drilled into them
don't
judge other people it's not nice and i
think it's not just coming from the left
you know as we say the so-called
tolerant left i think it's also
very often coming from the right where
there's this emphasis on like being nice
and not rocking the boat
and you know you can make certain
judgments but anything outside of that
range
you can't do and then there's probably a
vast center who's like
hey just don't defend anybody you know
and it you know your judgments probably
will offend people
it's a question of whether you're
offending um
badly or or well you know i used to
sometimes
say about my students this is a bit of a
different topic
i'd get you know evaluations and i'd be
like i don't want to be i don't want
everyone to say i'm a great teacher
i want the bad students to say that i'm
terrible and i want the good
students to say that i'm awesome because
then i know i'm actually doing a good
job
you know if everybody thinks i'm doing
great then i'm probably not and if
everybody thinks i'm doing terrible i
probably
am you know
well let's yeah let's get let's get into
some cases so
we're gonna we're gonna read some of
these
more or less verbatim we might shorten
some of these a bit
and we're obviously we're going to
change the language a bit as well
and we're going to comment on some of
the ones that we found the most
interesting we're going to alternate
back and forth
but but dan and i have both have ideas
about these that we
want to explore and i think you'll get
to see how useful
some of these could be for promoting
moral decision making and
deep thinking about ethical issues do
you want to do the first one
absolutely so this actually voted the
most difficult decision to make in 2020.
so am i the jerk for saving one sister's
life and not the other
i a 22 year old female have identical
twin little sisters or half sisters who
are both 16
and both have serious kidney issues they
have both
sadly reached a point where without a
kidney transplant their quality of life
will continue to climb
and they might not see the other side of
20. obviously
myself and my mom are devastated with
this news
it wasn't expected that they would be in
this position so young
for some background one of my sisters
sarah
is very much a tomboy like me and we are
really
close and enjoy a lot of the same things
we are like two peds in a pod
and not to say i don't love my other
sister jade
but we simply aren't that close she's a
little more girly
doesn't have many shared interests as me
and sarah do
and so we just don't hang out as often
i also don't see jade as much in general
sarah
doesn't like her dad's wife and so she
spends less time with them
while jade adores her so she has always
spent
more time at her dad's place both my mom
and their dad
and both of the girls were totally happy
with the setup by the way
jade also begged to go to a particular
boarding school so i don't see her
nearly as much as sarah
nor have i for a very long time maybe
one weekend a month for the last couple
of years and some more
over summer in the holidays i still love
her dearly but i hope it's
understandable now
that i'm just much more close with sarah
we are equally close we were equally
close until jade started doing her own
thing and making
choices for herself and i don't in any
way begrudge her that
i wouldn't say be sorry
i wouldn't say uh sarah and jade
didn't get along but they have
differently been
some big spats over the year we all got
tested to see if
it would be possible to do live
donations and i'm the only match
unfortunately i obviously only have two
kidneys i can only save one of my
sisters
there's every chance that they might get
a kidney from someone else
but right now they aren't a priority and
aren't high on the transplant list
i basically told my mom who told my dad
that i want to donate my kidney to sarah
i thought about it so much i know this
means that i am undeniably saying
i love sarah more than jade and i guess
i do
unsurprisingly all hell broke loose
about how
could i do this to jade how could i be
so
cruel why would i do this how could i
just play with their lives
i've been getting calls and texts from
everyone who knows about this
as far as i know neither sarah or jade
have been told of it i'm
i'm playing god here but it's my kidney
yeah i feel like scumford choosing one
sister over the other
but one of them is my best friend and
the other is well
she's not i feel like a monster for
saying it
and i know on a fundamental level it's
wrong
part of me wanted to flip a coin or
something but i couldn't my whole
family seems to be demanding me for i'm
sorry
demonizing me for making this choice
this is am i this is a tough one the
jerk
yeah you know this is a really
compelling one i guess
you know you can see why it was voted um
most difficult decision
to make right um now it's it's
interesting you you've got we were
talking before the show you've got some
definite thoughts about this so
why don't you launch into yours first
and then i'll add whatever i've got
because i think we're we mostly agree
about this right
actually let's vote so what do you think
um
not
okay is anybody else um
yes the parents
i think so too
yeah i i think she she definitely isn't
um
and we'll talk about why but but go
ahead what were your reflections on this
all right so like the first thing it's
like this is this is
from like a utilitarian standpoint it's
kind of a little bit of a trolley
problem
um either you do nothing and both
potentially die or you do something
and one dies and what doesn't one of
these options is
obviously better in that really
straightforward
calculation but you know as we see in
real life
this the trolley problems don't present
themselves in
nice straightforward ways and
so from the utilitarian position she
has like she's definitely making the the
morally good choice
to do something to save one of her
sisters
um and
[Music]
um from another argument is like um from
a bodily autonomy argument
no one has control over her own
particular
body or how she deals with it and so she
it is totally her decision
to make and it is absolutely up to her
um and whenever the parents are are
being
upset about this they're trying to
assert
their you know some sort of right over
her body
to choose how she uses it it's
interesting too with this case that uh
as you pointed out there's really
there's three possibilities she doesn't
give a kidney to anybody or she gives a
kidney to
the sister who she has more affinity
with or she gives a
kidney to the sister she has less
affinity with somebody
you know you only have one kidney to
give and to say that
it's um you know she's playing god and
she's being a monster or anything like
that
because she's not giving it to one
daughter it seems like she'd be
that logic should carry forward and
she'd be just as much of a monster if
she does give a kidney to that daughter
because she's not giving the other
kidney
or not giving the other daughter a
kidney obviously she doesn't want to
give away both kidneys
because then she's the worst off um so
there's something kind of weird about
this
right yeah the thought i had while
reading through this was
that there's not actually a problem like
there's definitely a problem with like
medical problems these two
young girls are are have a serious
medical condition
and um they could potentially die here
in
the near future um
and that is a bad situation
but it's now much worse apparently from
the perspective of the parents
because now there is a chance at least
for one of them
to um live yeah but
that choice isn't in their hands and so
i i wonder if part of the reason why
they're so
angry about this is that they're
they're removed from their agency
in oh in order to like how they choose
to protect
one of their children over the other so
there's kind of a displacement going on
yeah that's that's an interesting
insight i hadn't thought of that um
yeah that that actually that makes a lot
of sense
i do want to say two two other things um
so one is from a utilitarian perspective
you know it depends on whose
utilitarianism we're looking at if we're
if we're looking at it like just in the
sense so let's produce the best outcomes
overall
then it's indifferent which do which
daughter gets preferred and
and so you know we just pick one um
maybe you could flip a coin but she's
ruled that out
but the utilitarians would also say like
jeremy bentham would say
um benevolence this you know love for
another person
that's a good motive and acting on that
doesn't
make this a bad situation
and so i think bentham would actually be
for
um giving the kidney to the most favored
daughter he'd say that's that's the
right way to go and
the parents are actually like
diminishing people's
pleasure in the situation by
deliberately picking
a bad interpretation of it you know and
it also reminded me of thinking about a
manual kant
you know kant says that
when we do the right thing but we do it
motivated by like sympathy or affection
or something like that
it's not a moral action the only way
that you can really tell
this is kind of perverse the only way
you can really tell if something is a
moral action is if you don't want to do
it
you know if if you have you just
recognize that it's the right thing to
do and you allow that to motivate things
and even go against your inclinations
and so in this case
this would be like you know well i i'm
tempted to give my
kidney to this one sister who i i do
love more
and i'm deliberately going to give it to
the other one and to me
that strikes me as perverse well if you
took that
extended like wouldn't it be that uh
it would be even better to give it to
someone that you don't know
that you have no affinity for you're
right
yeah that should go into the donor list
you know
well yeah yeah yeah um and there's
definitely
you know certain moral systems that
would prefer that
yeah although there's you know there's
something screwy about those i think i i
think you know being willing to give to
somebody within your family
um there's there's something there is
something noble about that
you know so definitely
have certain biological imperatives that
lead us towards that aren't there
that's true uh although you could also
you know i think i've
mentioned on the show i have two uncles
and
they don't do this anymore but for a
long long time one of the uncles at
every family
dinner would say inevitably well you you
can pick your friends but you can't pick
your family
and then the other uncle would take
offense and he'd be like what do you
mean by that
because it was directed at him so i
don't know
maybe picking your family uh there could
be some natural
impulses towards it but you could also
be like i hate these people
[Laughter]
uh let's go let's go on to the next one
yeah
okay i'll i'll read this one um
am i the jerk for not giving a bully's
mom a promotion
is how it's framed i am a 27 year old
male that works for a midsize company in
my hometown
after college i moved back home to help
my mom get back on her feet after my dad
passed away
and i was hired on with my current
company and rose up fairly quickly
through the ranks
last year my younger sister was having
some issues at school with some girls
bullying her
and my mom was going through the school
trying to get it to stop
one day things got out of hand and one
of the girls tossed my sister's clothes
into the shower room during gym
and turned the showers on i left work to
take my sister some clothes because my
mom was at a medical appointment and i
saw a co-worker at the school
when my sister got home she told me that
the bully always has something mean to
say or do it turns out
the co-worker als had also left to pick
up her daughter because
she was the one who tossed the clothes
in the shower room
she saw me leaving with my sister and
approached me the next day at work to
apologize
i sent human resource and my boss an
email regarding the incident and didn't
think anything else
of it we had a position in management
open up three weeks ago and she was she
along with two others were up for the
job i interviewed two
out of the three as hr didn't think it
would be wise for me to interview her
and i agreed
at the end of the week my boss and i got
together to see where we stood on the
decision and he asked why i couldn't
sit in on her interview i reminded them
of the last incident and that was that
we ended up going with with one of the
other employees and my boss remarked to
me that her
failure in her home certainly didn't
help i guess i should feel bad about
that but honestly i don't
the woman approached me after work while
i was going to my car and asked if her
daughter's past action was an issue and
the deciding factor
and i told her she should speak to our
manager in hr if she felt it was a
biased interview
but gave her a little grin afterwards am
i the jerk
now what do you think we want to do this
at the same time
well i'll go first because i think you
you want first
i think uh i i think he's he's
kind of a jerk he's a jerk with a little
grin
you know he's not a jerk with um
the person not getting the job because
that was up to the
the the manager not not him right but i
i think that
it was a jerk move to like do the little
grin afterwards
all right i guess going back to my
previous point about
not labeling people on this was
definitely
partially a jerk move um
i don't know if he's like especially in
the how we define
the super jerk earlier yeah because he
doesn't seem like he's going out of his
way to
specifically cause harm and destruction
but he definitely
allowed it to happen in a way that was
not beneficial
for so there's a thoughtlessness right
yeah
so uh i i gave my ideas first how about
you go this time
um i think some of the framing in
it you know it's it's written in a very
neutral way but then
you got to wonder why why you sent a um
email to human resources in their and
his boss
just he doesn't say well i did it
because i was gone from company
property during during work time and so
i had to justify it in some way he just
says i
i told them about it you know um
and that seems it's not quite a red flag
it's
sort of like a pink flag gets raised at
that point for me
yeah what did you make of that oh the
email specifically
yeah i literally i had glossed over that
a little bit and i didn't actually see
it
um but now that you bring it up it was
like why are you doing that what is
the motivation what were you trying to
like besides
like hey i was away from work but you
know shouldn't you have told your
boss unless you don't trust your boss
and yeah
i guess you could be you know doing a
little bit of cya there
you know we we often do emails when we
want to make sure that things are being
recorded
you know but you could say like i had to
go and you know drop off clothes for my
sister and leave it at that without
saying she was bullied by
so and so yeah right yeah
like that tells you why you were gone
everything else is
superfluous to that particular situation
in regards to your job
yeah now this one is an interesting one
because he is asking
you know am i the jerk um and and it was
titled
uh for not giving a bully's mom a
promotion as if he
somehow had charge of that when when
clearly it's not
his call it's the it's his boss's call
um so he's that's not jerkish behavior
that but it is bad
practical reasoning taking
responsibility for things that aren't
really within
your agency right
so did that raise any red flags for you
or
um like the way that he
regarded
his co-workers uh control over
their child no i it's
although that's interesting too yeah i
mean blaming the the parent for the
child is
that can be problematic at times i'm
talking more about like him
acting as if he is like responsible for
her not getting the promotion
and then on the other hand not being
responsible for it
you know yeah like he's trying to have
it both ways
kind of yeah yeah
she's definitely taking a little bit of
pleasure now there's definitely like
some shot and friday here
um but i think it's really kind of like
this misplaced
you know retribution or revenge that is
really directed at the child of this
person
okay and and not at the person itself
yeah
and the only way that he can do anything
about it is by
interfering with her job hiring thing
so i guess at first saying that like i
want to
recuse myself from having the interview
with this person because i know that i
have a bias
that was a good decision but to
um to go
out and and make a
to tell the story about what had
happened with this
yeah employees child um is
like slander the person in the middle of
the interview yeah
in my opinion especially because that
has
almost nothing to do with the ability of
that person to actually do that job
if you're trying to base the giving that
uh job to someone based on their merits
of their ability
then this is kind of outside of that
yeah it's like a little poison pill
right
right yeah i think i'm with you on that
um any other ideas of
about this what did you make of the the
grin thing
yeah he's definitely taking pleasure in
it okay
and so uh you know i kind of feel like
taking pleasure at
the this misfortune of others is
probably not the best
you know moral decision there yeah
that's yeah is that even a decision
on his part um it might not be a
decision it might just be a
let's call it a reaction but it's still
it's still indicative of character right
right like that you you have at some
point
defined that this is good yeah all right
right
either consciously or subconsciously um
and you are acting like
at the moment the way it reads though um
it seems like the grin is not just like
oh i was grinning to myself
as i was walking away he says i gave
her a little grin you know so it's like
kind of
drive it home to her it's communicative
it's it's
it's rubbing salt in the wound a little
bit yeah i think that's a good way to
put it
yeah let's let's take one more i think
i don't know that we're going to have
that much time should we do the fact
checking one or should we do um
the toy burglar one what
what's your preference uh the toy
burglar is shorter so let's do that one
okay i i think it's a very funny one it
is
okay so am i the jerk for making my
daughter think that a toy burglar
will steal some of my daughter's toys if
she is misbehaving
that's how it's titled um ever since my
daughter was five she's now
eight i'd tell her that a man called
the toy burglar will take her toys away
and give them to a child who is well
behaved if she acts up
i even had my current boyfriend dress
up as the toy burglar and speak to her
while she was misbehaving
he dressed up in a ski mask with black
and white top
and some red pants with a red scarf
after meeting him she started to believe
me
even more and now when i bring up the
toy burglar she will stop
misbehaving and say sorry for whatever
she did
my mom thinks it's cruel to make up a
false character for my
daughter to be scared of and thinks i
should stop but i think
it's no different than santa like if my
daughter is well behaved
i'll have the toy burglar randomly send
her a gift
am i the jerk for doing this
okay so let's let's think about whether
we want to say
she is or whether she isn't or whether
anybody
else is um did i go first
yeah you go first i guess i'm feeling
muddled about this
i feel like there's aspects of this that
i don't like and there's aspects of this
that i'm
i'm kind of okay with
so i think she actually is a jerk
um and i wonder with myself
about you know i i do find this very
funny um
but clearly the daughter is um
having some anguish because of this and
i wonder if i'm not a jerk for enjoying
this one so much
the prospects thinking about it um
i don't know that that's that's a good
question
um i don't think that the mother's being
a jerk
um we can ask about the boyfriend is he
a jerk for participating in this what do
you think
he is
yeah like to to not only like
make up a story but to actually then
perpetrate a
a you know deliberate falsehood of like
yeah um it's very specific too you know
a ski mask black and white top and red
pants with a red scarf
it's like what um uh where's waldo meets
carbon san diego
or like the or the hamburglar hamburglar
yes
[Laughter]
so so i guess the the key question we
have to ask here is
you know there's already like a
mythology that our kids participate in
we were talking about santa claus
earlier and and i suppose we could talk
about the tooth fairy easter bunny all
the things that
you know they put into cartoons now
i was telling you how when i was a kid
they were the leprechauns who'd come to
our house you know on st
patrick's day and bring green candy and
turn like turn the toilet water green
and the milk green and all that and of
course i got a little
green footprints in my house did you
really yeah oh
interesting i i haven't met too many
people whose houses the leprechauns came
to
you know um and there's other things we
you know maybe we could come up with
like uncle sam for the fourth of july or
whatever right
if you're bad uncle sam takes you out
back and spanks you or
something like that straps you to a
rocket
there you go you know i think mcdonald's
actually you know
mentioning the hamburglar kind of tried
to do something like that
back when they used to have characters
like mayor mcgees and the hamburglar
who'd run around stealing things and
there was grimace and there are a few
other ones i don't really remember too
well
um is it is it wrong to introduce like
new characters deliberately to produce
compliance on the part of children
because that's what this is about i was
really interested about because i was
thinking about this in the way of like
developmental psychology
okay and how like
i'm definitely not an expert in this but
i do know that there are there are
certain
times and levels of when people
define things or why things are bad yeah
and and early on it's very much
like a um a consequentialist like you
know
right i don't like that it tastes good i
get to eat that that's good
you know it's very kind of like base
passions type thing
um and it seems like this this character
kind of is
latching into this like really early
developmental thing
uh but then the the thing that i don't
like about it at least to a certain
extent is that you are
creating this this fiction that is not
based in reality whatsoever
and you know when do you need to stop
uh propagating that that fiction
another thing about that too is if this
kid goes to school and talks to the
other kids
about you know it's one thing to say
like i'm i'm being good because i don't
want to get on santa's naughty list and
the other kids who believe in santa are
like oh yeah me either you know
but if you go to school and you're like
the toy burglar is gonna take away my
toys
you might actually get you know picked
on by by the other kids maybe they're
the mom's kind of setting their kid up
for that right
we wanted to talk about a practice and
this is one i think that we may have
mentioned in earlier shows
but i think a lot of this really drives
it home it's this thing that comes from
you know a lot of people but epictetus
in particular the great stoic
philosopher
he says that um you know like something
bad happens to you
think about what it would be like if it
happened to somebody else or do you have
the same attitude
towards it so your cup gets broken it's
the end of the world but you know your
buddy's cup gets broken you're like oh
you can get another cup
um well let's like make a little bit
more
it is your favorite cup is that cup that
your grandma gave you
which is both like uh sentimental and
also was like just a really great cup
yeah okay yeah so
how can we how can we apply that and
what does that have to do with these
am i the the jerk things i i think
that you know we're invited to kind of
look at things from other people's
perspectives and then pass judgment on
them but we can think about our own
behavior and the things that set us off
and
think about whether whether they should
right
right like it it's that that distancing
from the thing like we
become attached to things uh a lot and
easily so and and especially
our thoughts we become attached to our
thoughts and our our own
to judge a way of reasoning yeah to
judgment okay and
and sometimes these are some of the most
uh hard rooted in us
and it takes a lot to jolt us
out of that you know that thought
pattern
yeah well we're almost at the end of the
hour so we have some final thoughts for
you you want to lead us out
yeah robert sutton leads us with these
words
um it was a literally written
the book on the topic uh
on these jerk seas super jerks
bottom line super jerks need someone in
their life
to tell them they're being a super jerk
[Music]
you